foreign
let's roll up to Oklahoma in Tulsa and
talk to good man Kyle what's up Kyle
oh my gosh I am on the phone with Dr
John delone actually I'm just AI I'm
just a computer version of myself what's
up I hope you can be just as helpful
yeah wait dude way more helpful with a
computer what's up awesome
um my gosh um so I have a question but I
I
my wife and I real quick if you don't
mind go for it man
so I've I've been drinking an ocean of
baloney Kool-Aid uh over the last month
like 60 episodes something like that and
uh yesterday I told my wife uh I cut I
took out the bananas from the freezer
cut off the tips because that's what she
asked me to do and I didn't do it
because I thought she was being silly
and I told her that it was wrong of me
to do that and invalidate her feelings
just because and
exercise my control over it and say nope
I'm not cutting off the tips and she
goes you've been listening to your
podcast again haven't you
see for all the fruit lovers out there I
got your back guys I got your back well
done Kyle I'm glad you making those big
changes
I'm still cheating on her and I still
drink too much but I'm cutting the tips
off the bananas we're starting baby
steps Kyle way to go yeah way to go
um so my question
um my uh my oldest son is 20 years old
um he's been estranged for we've been
estranged for quite some time
um and he recently uh in the last couple
weeks uh started calling and wants to
start to
rebuild the relationship why are you
estranged
um uh
I gave him a really rough childhood
um and then when he was about 12 his mom
and I got divorced and I moved away
when you say you gave him a rough
childhood what does that mean
oh shoot
um
for a long time I refuse to admit
um that I was being abusive
um never left like bruises or anything
like that but just constant
yelling screaming couldn't he couldn't
do anything right
um escalating consequences
um
it was just
I can't imagine how miserable he was
growing up we'll flip the switch for you
man
hold on let me just say this
um I've got a little boy myself
and so I'm I'm gonna be a super candid
with you is that cool
yep yep I got a little boy myself and so
part of me
has an insta I can't describe it other
than it's like a thermometer like an
insta rage inside of me when I when I
hear this and
I also have like an instant sense of
compassion
because what you just said out loud is
really hard to do
there's not and there's not a lot of
Oklahoma dads
who are willing to look back and go what
have I done
right and so I'm proud of you we'll flip
that switch for you man
[Music]
unto you really
um
um but starting to listen to your show
and how you talk about
trauma and how it affects little kids
and how they hold on to that forever and
well then hold on to it just it just
becomes their nervous system it just
becomes wired into their bodies right
it's not like they're like just let it
go like no that's just how their bodies
have chosen to keep them safe so he
moved away with your ex-wife and then
you get remarried have a new family I
did okay how's that going
uh it's going awesome have you learned
from your your past mistakes oh
immensely okay for you man good for you
so then so this so he's he's almost a
grown man now and he reaches out why'd
he Reach Out
um
so he he did come down here and he moved
in with me when he was 17
um with the agreement to finish his
final year of school
um and then covid hit and he lost all of
his new friends that he had made
um down here and so he moved back to
Wisconsin with his mom
um
and
things just got worse and worse
um there's a long long history of
lying and manipulation and just
not taking responsibility for anything
um do you know that you know how that
develops right
just just people listening if you are a
young kid
and you can't do anything right and
everything is met with screaming and
spanking times too hard and you know the
difference and
a moving Target on how do I keep dad
from getting so mad
a kid peels off and learns how to be
very deceptive and never tell the truth
because he doesn't you don't you don't
say it's a very adaptive strategy
yeah that makes perfect sense it keeps
the young kid alive
and also destroys his adulthood
because then he gets fired from jobs as
he should and he gets his his romantic
Partners leave him as they should
because he can't tell the truth he's
just to become deceptive so and also
this often comes with substance abuse
issues is he struggling with that too
um no okay
good for him nope
so um what's your what's your hesitancy
there's just there's been so many
bridges burned and the original divorce
was just so extremely toxic
um the marriage was extremely toxic and
I took out a lot of my frustrations
um with my marriage on him
um because nothing was changing in the
marriage so hold on it sounds like you
burned the bridges
and anytime somebody has a relationship
dysfunction with a child I'm always
going to look at the adult in the room
and say you got to go first
if there's ever going to be a bridge
built you've got to build it you can't
expect a kid to build that bridge back
it's not their job
yep
um and we tried
um and when when he came down here when
he was 17 to live with us
um we tried yeah but I mean you you went
from one teeter-totter to the other
like that like that's that's a lot
because even if he wants to if he moves
back in with you
as a 20 year old as a 17 year old he may
want to with all of his heart to refine
his dad and who am I and I've I've grown
up and all those things dad used to get
so mad at me about I'm good it's
different now
but that 17 year old's body is every
time you walk in the room is like run
every time you give him something like a
a chore or say hey I told you to pick up
that that whatever and you were right to
tell him his body goes to Defcon one
and so I I think you over hit it right
you over corrected from abusive to
completely out of my life to move back
in that's a lot versus
let's be I mean you can't just drop a
newly fully formed Bridge across a a big
river right you got to build it slat by
slat and I think that's what you'll have
to do here
yep
um there is a lot of history
um
and stuff that he doesn't know about
because about what the divorce and he
doesn't does he need to who cares
you were a grown ass man and you treat
took it out on a kid I don't care what
was happening in your marriage I know
that sounds callous but he doesn't need
to know what happened in your marriage
and how awful his mom was he doesn't
need to know any of that
he needs his dad to sit down at a
restaurant somewhere between here and
Wisconsin and say I wrote a letter that
I'm going to read to you
and it starts with dear son I'm so sorry
I let you down
I didn't know what I was doing I was
over my head my marriage was a wreck I
had no Tools in my tool kit and I loved
you and I showed you in the worst
possible way
I've sent you on a path to learning to
be dishonest to get what you need
because I couldn't give it to you and I
didn't give it to you and fulfill in the
blank the only way this works Kyle is
you take a knee in front of that 20 year
old and say I've failed you and that
ends today
and I did okay how'd that go
um I'm proud of you for doing that by
the way that takes a lot of Courage I
make it sound all easy on the radio
that's hard to do how'd that go it's
probably the it was probably the hardest
thing I'd ever said to anybody in my
life did you feel 50 pounds lighter when
you after you're saying that stuff
oh yeah I bet so so so yes so tell me uh
how'd it go
um went good
um he thanked me for being honest about
it because it's what he had accused me
of for years and I denied it yeah
um and I think because when he first
called me I was like man I don't know if
I can do this with him right now
um
it doesn't count over the phone by the
way yeah over the phone to Step One it
has to happen in person so if you all
talked on the phone and you said a bunch
of stuff that's cool that's a cool like
partial First Step but that's not it
yep
um so yeah we're trying to set up a time
to meet he was in Iowa now
um so we're trying to set up a time that
we can meet and get together Kyle
don't set up a time get in your car and
go see your son
this isn't something you arrange this
isn't something that you walk out of
your job and say I'll be back I'm going
to get my son
like the the
even if you drive all the way from Tulsa
to Iowa for a two and a half or three
hour meal together and then you drive
home
but he has to know dad's coming to get
me
there's no more tiptoeing and this like
what happened has happened the only
thing you can change is what happens
next
Fair
absolutely Fair
and here's how I think you
here's how I think you guys start
building those slots back I think you
make a commitment to yourself and to him
I'm going to write him a letter every
week and mail it to him
just thinking about you wouldn't you
know I'm so proud of you just want you
to love you
one time you're not probably gonna
remember this but one time when you're a
little kid fill in the blank that's it
and what's gonna happen in real short
order by the end of this time next year
he's gonna have 52 letters from his old
man he's even gonna get annoyed that you
keep sending them
and after letter 36 he's like Dad I'm
we're good you don't keep sending these
you're like I know
but you will never go another week of
your life not knowing that your dad
loves you and is committed all in on you
now that does not mean he gets access to
your checking account that doesn't mean
that you become an ATM for him or
whatever that means I'm gonna love you
so why did he Reach Out
no I'm going to
no no why did he reach out oh why did he
reach out
um
so a lot of the patterns that I put on
him when he was a kid he's exhibiting
now as a young adult yeah and he got
as far as I know got kicked out of his
mom's house
um
we'll just say not being kind to his
younger sister okay
there is a moment when you confront your
son on that
and you say I let you down you cannot
let the cycle continue it has to stop
with you
what's up with me and SW
yep is he calling I know where I'm
struggling yeah go ahead because
but I know all these things about
that he's kept secret from me as far as
his home life and
fighting with his sister and his mom and
I I feel responsible for that and at the
same time I also feel like
he needs to be held accountable for that
because some of it's his own decisions
he's a 20 year old man now he's a 20
year old man that's exactly right
and
sometimes accountability looks like hey
I can't get you out of jail I'll hold
your hand I'll sit with you
you're not gonna do this alone
his experiences now are a context not an
excuse he does not have free reign
because you didn't show up for him as a
kid he does not have free reign to burn
other people to the ground
he's got to be held accountable good for
his mom for kicking him out of his house
if he's making it unsafe for his little
sister good for her for holding
upholding boundaries and if he's
reaching out he didn't see that coming
well if he's reaching out to you just
because he's looking for a crash pad you
only need to have that conversation
because he has no interest in in
rebooting your relationship he has ever
interest in just getting free rent and
that's two different things that's kind
of what I'm worried about is that the
reach out was for ulterior motives
probably probably
but tell him
I love you too much we are combustible
we're gonna have to build this thing
back slowly
and I will contribute a couple hundred
bucks a month to an apartment out here
if you want to move out here but you're
gonna have to work too
oh my gosh after all this you're just
gonna no I love you so much you gotta
learn some lessons that I should have
taught you when you're little and
I can't sleep at night if I let this
thing continue
yeah so I think I think the re-entry
here has to be you and your new wife
setting the boundaries right like
laughs
son I don't engage with folks that lie
that's a that's a choice as a grown man
that I've made
I also don't walk away from people that
I love
that's what I'm asking you don't choose
to walk away from me by being dishonest
number two
when you move back in here that was not
we have to learn we have to teach our
bodies at each other is safe
it's not going to work for you to move
back in here apartments in this area
this much I'll contribute this much
I'll call my buddy at the shop to help
you get a job or whatever he's doing
help him get to college or whatever
but and there's going to be some stars
to stop some ups and downs he's going to
get mad you can invite him to counseling
with you if you'd like to
But ultimately you can't be responsible
for his healing as much as you want to
try to get a redo on that what happens
what you can do is love him right now
but he's a grown man now he's got to
make his own choices which is hard
yep I'm trying to support him
anyway but financially I did send him
your show he started listening he went
all the way back to the first episode
he's listening from the back forward
um
I I think you let him know hey I'm
coming on Saturday
I'm coming next Friday
I'm taking you to dinner
and I think you and your wife figure out
how to make that happen financially
and time wise
and y'all talked on in person but you
gotta look him in the eye and I'd write
it down man because it can get real
heavy and it can get real blubbery and
be very hard I would look him in the eye
and read that letter to him
and then from there say what do you need
how can I love you right now
and then align what he's asked for with
those new boundaries
but yeah you may have taught him some
things as a young kid that doesn't give
him license to run over his little
sister or his mom or anybody like that
and here's the thing
did you play that right when he was
young no you didn't you let him down
and have you made it a mission in your
life to
not only
create new paths for your family that
you have now your new family but also
provide opportunities for him
to be a the dad that he didn't have
grown up absolutely and I commend you
for that it's hard
it's day by day there's a lot of guilt
and there's gonna be moments that come
up things probably you forgot that he
remembers you're going to feel guilty
about the challenge for you is going to
be to not go to shame
you did some stupid stuff when you were
young and in a toxic marriage but you're
not stupid stuff
that's the difference between guilt and
shame something you did versus something
you are
because now you're not that guy anymore
you're the dad that's going to run out
after his prodigal son and say please
come home I'm sorry
please come home
and by the way you can't stay in the
house you can stand apartment down the
street
and you got to get a job you got to go
to college
and I'll meet with you once a week if
that's what you want to do
we're gonna build a relationship back
Brick by Brick by Brick
we're not just gonna hand him the keys
to a new car we're not going to hand him
the keys to a new highway together y'all
gonna rebuild this brick but that for
all the parents listening
that rebuilding relationship with your
kids starts with you
starts with you what if my kid's the one
it starts with you
you're the mom you're the dad make the
call